bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction de TVfil 78 il est 18h si vous
nous suivez en direct et dans
l'actualité evvelinoise aujourd'hui pour
la première fois depuis 2006 la France
accueille les mondiaux de cyclisme sur
piste et c'est à 50 ans eneline
champions sont en action depuis ce matin
au Vélodrome nous irons sur place
retrouver notre correspondant attentat
simetière profané les Juifs en France
ont-ils peur le président Hollande veut
en tout cas les rassurer inviter le
Rabin Mendel Nissen bum responsable de
la communauté juive à montinil
Bretonneux et puis 10 épisodes de 52
minutes pour raconter l'histoire du
jeune Louis XIV Versailles nouvelle
fiction historique de Canal Plus est en
tournage dans la ville royale les
coulisses du tournage supervisé
notamment par Jalil l'espert à qui on
doit le longmétrage Yv Saint-Laurent
c'est donc une première depuis presque
10 ans les mondiaux de cyclisme se
déroulent en France jusqu'au 22 février
les meilleurs pistars sont à Montini le
Bretonneux 6000 spectateurs présents
c'est un événement sportif majeur le
premier de cette envergure à se dérouler
ici dans ce complexe sur place Michel
elmidoro également Mélanie poket et
William l pour la technique Michell
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes dans
l'ensemble de ce vélodrome au plus près
des champions dans moins d'une heure la
cérémonie d'ouverture c'est ça il y a
énormément de monde ici on va dire que
l'ambiance est et Tobo fix les
Championnat du Monde commencent très
bien vous entendez derrière moi les les
coups de départ il y a énormément de
monde on a pu voir des Allemands des
Danois des français bien sûr en grand
nombre des cantinois également en grand
nombre on a pu voir des enfants des
personnes un peu plus âgées et le le
spectacle se déroule bien sur donc dans
les tribunes mais également sur la piste
les Français ont réalisé un record de
France notre consultant yen du Jarrier
justement très beau record de France
pour commencer très beau record de
France pour les Français là on vient de
voir une chute des Australiens juste
dans le premier age bon le point fort
pour le point bon du la journée c'est
que les Français sont qualifiés de toute
façon pour les les finales et pour le
premier tour du tournoi de de poursuite
qui aura lieu demain voilà là pour eux
le le le le challenge est accompli une
médaille est possible aujourd'hui euh il
va y avoir 4 secondes avec la première
équipe je ne sais pas s'ils avaient
encore de la réserve la fin de poursuite
est un petit peu difficile pour eux on
verra on verra demain il y a de toute
façon tant que la le dernier tour n'est
pas fini dernière poursuite on peut pas
on peut pas on peut pas savoir nous
rappelle un petit peu
l'équipe alors l'équipe est Enée par
Bryan Cocar le routier le routier de le
jeune Bryan Cocar ancien enfin
vicechampion olympique du du je trouve
plus l'épreuve mais à Londres et puis
vice-champion du monde aussi toujours
dans le dans le je retrouve pas du tout
lesépreuves mais donc donc voilà une
belle une belle équipe de France qui qui
est là en construction de toute façon
ils sont pas vraiment là pour pour venir
chercher un titre mais pour établir des
performances et pouvoir construire sur
le futur chez les filles ça é un peu
plus compliqué beaucoup plus compliqué
chez les filles je pense qu'il y avait
une erreur de de braquer vous saviez
vous le saviez on se faisait pas on se
faisait pas d'illusion voilà l'équipe de
France de poursuite chez les filles
c'était un peu
compliqué en plus peut-être une erreur
de braquer ça paraissait un peu gros
pour pour elle voilà pareil de toute
façon la poursuite chez les f que chez
les garçons est en construction il faut
il faut mettre tout ça en place et donc
il y a une cérémonie qui est prévu d'ici
une heure beaucoup de surpris c'est ça
appment beaucoup de surpris pour pour
cette pour cette cérémonie on on a hâte
de voir tout ça et donc ce soir surtout
on attend la vitesse par équipe et le
public répond présent aussi c'était
c'était pas un point d'interrogation
parce qu'on savait qu'il allait répondre
présent mais il y a vraiment beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui pour le premier jour
d'épreuv là même pour une qualification
de vitesse de poursuite par équipe je
suis agréablement surpris de voir le le
vélodrome plein à à 80 % quoi et il fait
très chaud sur dis tout à l'heure il
fait très chaud parce que l'UCI impose
une température à 25°gr dans l'enceinte
du Vélodrome pour les épreuves pour pour
ce type d'épreuve donc voilà oui tout le
monde a chaud donc le vélodrome compte 5
000 places il sera plein tout au long de
la compétition vraiment 5500 places
ouais tout est on est à guich et fermé
là il y a plus il y a plus de place
peut-être pour ce soir il peut-être Mo
encore de de se battre de se battre au
guichet mais à partir de demain c'est
plein c'est full et après il y aura les
têes d'affiche en plus qui vont ramener
du monde c'est ça donc oui ce soir on a
la vitesse par équipe demain on va avoir
le Kin avec François Pervis vendredi ou
samedi le kilomètre et puis la vitesse
aussi la vitesse individuelle que des
belles épreuves pour pour nos par avec
de vrais avec pour nos sprinter avec de
vraies chances de médaill et puis bah
dans les épreuves de fond aussi hein on
a plein de représentants qui peuvent
aller chercher de de belles de B
résultats donc l'objectif cinq médailles
c'est réalisable pour moi il est conçoit
pas qu'on nit pas une médaille par jour
sur ces 5 jours donc je pense qu'on en
aura plus et vous pensez qu'il y aura
pas trop de pression sur sur l'équipe de
France justement on voit les drapeaux de
partout c'est il y a pas trop de
pression justement la je la pression je
ne sais pas c'est quand même des des
choses qu'ils ont l'habitude de faire on
est on les sort pas de leur contexte ce
sont des épreuves où les gens se
rencontrent quand même régulièrement sur
les épreuves de Coupe du monde donc donc
ben non je pense que c'est plutôt une
pression qui une vraie motivation et qui
va être positive voilà tout à faittive
la cérémonie d'ouverture est prévue à
19h Wilfried merci Michel merci
également à notre consultant Yan
dejarnier et je le rappelle cette
cérémonie vous l'avez dit ce sera à 19h
nous y reviendrons bien sûr dans notre
prochaine édition sur TV film Michel
vous restez sur place avec également
Mélanie poet et William l merci les
mondiaux de cyclisme qui se déroule à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline en ce moment
peut-être en 2024 les GI à Saint-Quentin
en yeline c'est on mais pour l'instant
que pensez-vous d'un tel événement à
sa-quentin en Yveline de ces mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste c'est notre question
du jour vos réponses ah j'ai il me
semble que j'ai entendu parler mais j'ai
pas plus fait attention je suis pas trop
passionn de cyclisme mais c'est cool ça
ramène ça ramène un petit peu de lumière
sur sur sa50 on va dire alors moi je
fais pas de vélo mais je trouve ça bien
pour la région ça va dynamiser un petit
peu le coin et ça peut-être permettre de
connaître un peu le le sujet parce que
je connais pas trop le vélo moi ben
comme j'étais en cours on a déjà
travailler sur la création de depuis la
création du Vélodrome et du coup on a
beaucoup entendu parler de ce Mondial
c'est plutôt pas mal vu que c'est à 51
et que du coup on peut nous en profiter
habitant de 5tin ah ben je trouve ça
très bien moi je trouve que c'est une
opportunité pour Montini enfin 50 ans en
Iline se faire connaître et dans la
perspective peut-être des Jeux
Olympiques sans Paris voilà pour ce
micro trottoir signé etodim moan et
puisque l'on parle de ces Mondiaux on va
y rester encore quelques instants à
travers le prisme des petits nation qui
participe parmi les 38 pays sélectionnés
on retrouve ainsi l'Afrique du Sud les
champions d'Afrique en titre qui ne
possèdent pas les mêmes moyens que les
équipes européennes reportage William l
et Michael midoro c'est l'une des plus
petites délégations de ces championnat
du monde sur piste les trois
sud-africains Eugène sou amerine wenold
et marchka maté sont arrivés ce mardi au
Vélodrome de 50 ans en yelin championne
d'Afrique en titre l'équipe dispose
pourtant d'un budget réduit la
fédération SUD africaine a seulement
payé les billets d'avion de la
délégation le staff est lui composé
d'une seule personne ben moi ma fonction
c'est je fais tout je fais le mécanicien
le coach sur la piste le manager avec
quelques petits mots pour réconforter et
mettre less les courur en confiance je
m'occupe de toute la logistique donc
voilà c'est beaucoup beaucoup de travail
il faut s'investir au niveau du matériel
les sud-africain disposent également du
strict minimum au niveau du matériel on
est limité je me suis fait prêter du
matériel par la société une société du
coin d'ailleurs les coureurs ont un vélo
chacun donc il y a pas de vélo rechange
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
pendant la compétition pendant qu'un
coureur court comme il n'a pas vélo
rochante je suis obligé d'adapter
rapidement un vélo d'un coureur qui
court pas pour avoir un véou de secours
en cas de en cas de chute ou en cas de
crevison en cas
d'incident contrairement aux autres
nations les trois sportifs sud-africains
ne dorment pas à l'hôtel mais chez
l'habit le team manager Franco canellaa
a trouvé un logement àrappe pour
réaliser des économies leur haôte a
réaménagé la pièce en poussant les
meuble et en installant des matelas sur
le sol il les accueille gracieusement
voilà les circonstances ont fait que moi
je pouvais accueillir particulièrement
cette période là et voilà si eux ça leur
convenait parce que bon voilà c'est pas
non plus un hôtel 4 étoiles ou 5 étoiles
mais dans dans l'esprit voilà si ça leur
convenait c'était parfait apparemment
c'est ça leur va très bien et moi c'est
cool ça me permet de dire discuter un
peu avec eux d'échanger un peu la
culture de la culture du vélo qui est un
peu différente chez eux et puis la
discipline
aussi c'est incroyable de rester ici
avec Philippe et de découvrir la façon
de vivre à la française et de voir ça
c'est un véritable
trésor les Sud-Africains ne sont pas
venus en touriste sur cette compétition
ils espèrent réaliser quelques records
nationaux leur meilleure chance la
couruse de 26 ans MKA
maté
mon but est de réaliser des performances
sur la poursuite individuelle et de
battre le record de l'Afrique du Sud
c'est un record qui date de 15
ans je suis également engagé dans le
scratch j'espère obtenir une bonne place
si mes gens me
permettent une fois la compétition
terminée le dimanche 22 février les
Sud-Africains prépareront dans la foulée
leur valise le départ pour Johannesburg
est déjà programmé pour le lundi matin
pas question de faire du tourisme
objectif réaliser une nouvelle fois des
économies on quitte ces Mondiaux nous y
reviendrons bien sûr tout au long de la
semaine sur cette antenne mais une
information concernant à présent les
transports le rere e qui relie
Saint-Lazare à la bienlieu est va être
prolongé vers la défense d'ici à 2022 la
ligne sera connectée à la SNCF vers
montelajolie où les travaux vont
commencer dès le mois de mai un projets
ambitieux des travaux lourds qui
permettront à terme un temps de trajet
diminuer d'une vingtaine de minutes en
moyenne
le mobile antisémite finalement avéré
dans le cadre de la profanation du
cimetière juif de sarunion le procureur
a demandé cet après-midi la mise en
examen à ce titre des C mineur
interpellé lundi dans Le Barin je reçois
ce soir le Rabin Mel Nissan bum
bienvenue sur ce plateau bonsoir vous
êtes le responsable de la communauté
juive sur montinil breteneux j'aimerais
tout d'abord avoir votre sentiment votre
réaction à cette information cette mise
en ex main les suspects sont jeunes
entre 15 et 17 ans retenir ce motif
antisémite ça vous place dans quel état
d'esprit
euh
d'une nous allons dire c'est un dégoût
c'est désolant c'est-à-dire que ça
arrive d' une chose sont des mineurs si
jeunes sont des jeunes qui peuvent qui
auraient pu qui peuvent s'amuser qui
encore beaucoup de choses devant eux
faire leurs études n'ont rien commencé
encore dans la vie et venir à faire ces
actes des actes est proclamé en tant
qu'acte antisémite le dire le clairement
jusqu'au jusqu'au point même comme vous
venez de le dire que le procureur décide
une mise en examen euh c'est où il faut
réellement repenser un petit peu à notre
jeunesse ça veut dire qu' on est passé à
côté de quelque chose le système
éducatif les politiques sont passés à
côté de quelque chose clairement oui oui
oui il faut revoir peut-être notre
système éducatif c'est ce qu'on entend
en ce moment alors je ne suis pas
spécialiste en la matière mais peut-être
il y a eu ces attentat en France dans le
magasin Hyper cacher à Paris il y a eu
l'agression de militaire aussi à Nice
devant un centre communautaire juif des
attaques aussi à l'étranger à Copenhague
comment réagit la communauté juive en
France et peut-être plus
particulièrement à 50 an d'iveline sur
montinille Bretonneux j'imagine que vous
avez ces conversations bien sûr disons
que depuis les derniers attentats ce
sont des conversations qui reviennent et
qui reviennent assez souvent et j'allais
dire même de manière constante
euh le gouvernement la République a très
bien réagi avec la sécurité mise sur
tout tous les sur tous ces lieux
sensibles et
cetera y compris d'ailleurs sur 50 ans
en ieline et dans la région de manière
générale
mais ce sont des choses qui reviennent
et là on est en train de revivre d'une
certaine manière alors c'est vrai que
c'était pas en France mais en Europe pas
trop loin un petit peu le même scénario
François Hollande qui déclare la
République vous défendra est-ce que
c'est suffisant vous avez ce besoin
d'être protégé aujourd'hui il y a une
crainte il y a une peur
oui c'est-à-dire que savoir juste avoir
la conscience que la République est
présente que la République est là la
communauté n'est pas seule nous savons
nous qu'on a toujours pu compter sur la
République nous avons bien vécu en
France nous allons continuons à le faire
je l'espère et c'est sur quoi nous
comptons donc un petit peu ces mots ces
mots d'encouragement ce déplacement qui
a été fait par le président par le
Président de la République pardon sont
vraiment des choses importante c'est un
signe fort pour nous on entend souvent
parler de de peur dans les médias c'est
pour ça que je vous pose cette question
euh est-ce que c'est le cas-ce qu'il y a
des familles qui vont partir par exemple
de Saint-Quentin qui émettent le souhait
de de partir de partir en
Israël est-ce que ça reste marginal
finalement dire que c'est marginal non
mais c'est des discussions en tous les
cas qui reviennent c'està-dire on veut
voir la suite est-ce que les choses vont
s'arranger est-ce que nous voulons
rester nous voulons pas partir nous
sommes viens ici h le donc est-ce que ce
sont des choses qui vont s'arranger par
la suite aujourd'hui le gouvernement
réagit très bien nous comptons sur lui
pour qu'on puisse avancer et nous
espérons que les choses se calmeront
puisque l'on parle des médias je vais
aussi profiter de votre présence pour
vous faire réagir au au traitement de
cette actualité de ces attentats de ces
actes antisémites Jean-Jacques Bourdin
journaliste sur rmcbfm qui demande à
Roland Dumas si manuel Val c'est sous
influence juive de par son épouse ça
vous a choqué cette
question un petit peu oui oui c'estàd
c'est dire qu'en fait que les ces
interventions de l'État du Premier
ministre sont réellement des choses qui
sont sous influence parce qu'il est sous
influence je trouve ça un petit peu
déplacé il y a eu aussi ces appels
répétés de Benjamin netaniahou le
Premier ministre israélien au Juifs
d'Europe pour qu'ils émigrent en masse
vers Israël le grand Rabin du nadmark
lui s'est dit déçud par toutes ces
remarques et vous je pense que les
choses devraient être remises dans leur
contexte c'est dire le gouvernement
israélien est très bien fait son travail
nous sommes en France la communauté
juive française est très vieille
rappelons quand même Queau Moyen-Âge il
avait le grand Rachi qui était un
vigurant en Champagne et donc donc un
des grands commentateur de la de la
Torah donc la communauté juive est quand
même trèsville en France elle restera je
pense depuis Israël on vous appelle à
revenir à venir tout simplement alors ce
n'est pas à revenir c'est à venir à
venir tout simplement à venir non non
c'est que c'est pour ça que je dis que
chacun devrait un petit peu rester à sa
place aujourd'hui est-ce que vous vous
réunissez avec les fidèles vous pour
échanger est-ce qu'il y a des réunions
qui sont organisées comment ça se passe
actuellement alors il y a ces il y a ces
réunions il y a ces moments d'échang un
petit peu un petit peu qui sont un petit
peu conviviales un petit peu privé
c'estàdire sont sont ces réunions où on
veut parler on veut échanger on veut
dire nos sentiments qu'est-ce que chacun
ressent c'est ces moments d'échange un
petit peu des fois ces moments d'union
que nous avions besoin de pour se
renforcer simplement pour se dire des
des mots réconfortants l'un à l'autre
c'est dire que quand même on est bien et
pour préciser pour notre communauté ici
à montinu Bretonneux nous sommes
réellement très bien pas d'incident à à
signaler particulierers donc c'est vrai
que les événements nous touchent est-ce
qu'il y a une évolution particulière C
ces dernières années est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que la situation se
dégrade aussi ou est-ce que là c'est
c'est très ponctuel finalement alors
est-ce que ça fait plusieurs années déjà
que c'était assez latent alors on on
peut quand même constater que ça se
dégrade h on peut quand même constater
que ça se dégrade mais il faut espérer
que ça AR reste ponctuel dire que ça ne
se dégrade pas plus h que ça s'arrête
j'espère que ça reprendra pas mais on
peut voir quand même qu'il y a eu des
événement relativement de manière
ponctuelle il eu des événements par-ci
par là là on voit quand même un
antisémitisme qui remonte c'est
malheureux de dire ça redevient un petit
peu à la mode et ça il faudrait que ça
s'assue et on voit juste pour pour
conclure que vous avez organisé très
fréquemment vous venez sur sur ce
plateau pour évoquer à Na notamment vous
organisez dans les rues à 5quants en
neline à montinil Bretonneux pour aller
à la rencontre de la population de tout
le monde qu'il soit croyant ou non ça il
faut poursuivre ces efforts là aussi
est-ce qu'il y a des des efforts c'est
peut-être pas le terme mais des gestes à
faire d'ouverture de montrer d'expliquer
que finalement quelle que soit la
religion tout le monde est pareil et on
est là pour échanger même si ça paraît
tout bête à dire mais c'est toujours
important bien sûr bien sûr c'est ces
échanges ces échanges qui sont forts
c'est dire tout simplement se faire
connaître l'ignorance le plus grand
danger donc en fait se
montrer se montrer se faire connaître
que que les questions soient posées que
le réponse soi données
tout simplement se faire connaître aller
aller à la rencontre des gens à la
rencontre de la population la rencontre
de la rue ça nous ça au contraire oui
sont des choses à continuer et même
peut-être à renforcer merci m bom Rabin
président de la communauté juiv à
montinil Bretonneux d'être venu sur ce
plateau pour commenter cette triste
actualité merci à vous nous allons
repartir à présent sur ces mondiaux de
cyclisme qui s'organise actuellement à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline cyclisme sur
piste Michel midoro vous êtes toujours
sur place bien évidemment et puisque la
cérémonie maintenant ce sera dansu près
qu d'heure pour ceux qui nous suivent en
direct il est il est 18h15 aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mercredi vous êtes au côté
du président de l'agglomération de
saqutin Michel logier c'est ça WIF je
suis à côté de Michel logier donc
président dequtin et maire de mon breton
alors c'est un super événement vraiment
que véome vous êtes à mes côté regardez
ce vélodrome qui vibre et on en est que
au premières heures de cette compétition
don sachez que jusqu'à dimanche n
vraiment des moments importants pu voir
déjà c'est que les équipes de France
étaient en forme le record de France
déjà qui est déjà tombé donc c'est
vraiment exceptionnel et je pense que
les heures qui s'annoncent et les jours
à venir vont être exceptionnel à 50 he
et c'est vraiment un grand plus pour
pour moneneux et plus généralement pour
5antel ben c'est un plus pour c'est un
plus même déjà pour la France puisque
nous sommes quand même le premier
vélodrome de ce type sur le territoire
français don nous accueillons cette
compétition internationale à peine un
peu plus d'un an quelques jours près de
l'inauguration c'est déjà exceptionnel
et puis surtout le vrai Paris c'est
d'avoir rempli ce vélodrome tout au long
de la compétition 5 5000 plac
c'està-dire queà ce jour il y a plus
aucune place en vente tout est complet
et tous les pays que j'ai pu voir là
tous les représentants des différentes
formations sont vraiment surpris de ce
lieu agrement surpris et je pense que
c'est vraiment pour nous une très belle
victoire qui encre tout à fait le
vélodrome dans les événements sportifs
importants sur notre pays vous allez
avoir le temps un petit peu de de
regarder les courses ou l'emploi du
temps est très chargé alors je me suis
débrouillé pour que aujourd'hui mes
activités soient concentré le matin je
commence très tôt mais l'après-midi et
la soirée je serai ici pour vivre ces
événements puisque je dois aussi
accueillir différentes personnes parce
que c'est une compétition sportive mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de vendre le
territoire et donc je suis là aussi pour
vendre SaintQuentin aux entreprises au
représentants des autres pays voilà je
joue mon rôle de ambassadeur et vous
avez pu rencontrer quelques cycliste et
ben là tout à l'heure j'étais j'étais
tout simplement avec Robert Marchand qui
est vous savez notre centenaire qui est
sur 104e année et qui je pense dans
quelques minutes va sûrement faire un
tour de Vélodrome devant tout le monde
merci Michel logier merci à vous merci
Michel merci également à Michel logier
vous aavez compris beaucoup d'enjeux
autour de tout ça autour de ces
événements ça dépasse le cadre sportif
et le cadre sportif on va le dépasser
également à présent avec de la culture
nous en parlions déjà hier le château de
versaill vient d'accueillir le tournage
de plusieurs scènes de la nouvelle série
signée canal plus intitulé tout
simplement Versailles elle sera à
l'antenne à la rentrée prochaine les
coulisse yolen Torz et William
l silence ça tourne au château de
Versailles dans 3
2 retour au 17e siècle avec le Roi
Soleil et les costumes d'époque une
série diffusée à l'automne prochain sur
Canal Plus est actuellement en tournage
versaill revient sur la vie du jeune roi
à la fin des années 1660 sur sa bataille
pour imposer son pouvoir et sur la
construction du château mettez-vous sur
l'esplanade comme ça on va vous placer
là-bas avec ses milliers de visiteurs
chaque jour le château de Versailles
s'adapte les travaux sont interrompus le
temps du tournage il faut une
coordination exceptionnelle pour que le
château de Versailles soit disponible
vide ouvert et puisse accueillir un
tournage comme ça qu'on est pas au
milieu du tournage quelqu'un qui
traverse la cour au mauvais moment ça
n'est pas possible lorsqu'on fait des
films 10 épisodes tournés en anglais un
budget de 27 millions d'euros le plus
important jamais réuni pour une
production télé dans l'Hexagone à
l'image du film Marie- Antoinette de
sopia copola sortie en 2006 et tourné en
partie au château la série pourrait
avoir de multiples impacts en France
mais aussi à l'étranger il redonne le
désir à nos visiteurs de venir à
Versailles de redécouvrir ce lieu
magique il donne l'envie à d'autres
nations de de de découvrir mieux en en
se faisant expliquer les choses de
découvrir mieux les grands personnages
qui ont habité ce lieu donc c'est
forcément forcément des répercussions
exceptionnelles pour versaill en route
vers d'autres lieux de tournage les
camions ont déjà quitté la place d'armes
pour laisser place aux visiteurs
versaill TVfil 78
première et puisque l'on parle du
château sachez que l'établissement
public qui en assure la gestion a
réalisé plusieurs acquisitions ce début
d'année du portrait de Marie- Thérèse de
Savoie l'Almanac royale pour l'année
1752 en passant par le portrait de
madame Louise tout cela sera bien
évidemment à découvrir dans le musée au
cours des prochains mois maintenant pour
terminer ce journal nous parlons d'un
autre championnat le championnat des
Yvelines d'échec actuellement à maniermo
la compétition se termine ce weekend
l'occasion pour la fédération
départementale de promouvoir la
discipline dans cette commune de
l'agglomération le coup du berger à
Manil lesamoau le weekend dernier le
comité départemental Eveline échec
structure a organisé son 29e championnat
d'échec 44 participants venus de
différents club yvelinois s'affronte sur
deux weekends chaque joueur doit
disputer seette parti comme en fait je
suis en milieu de tableau sur le sur
l'ensemble des joueurs je me suis
retrouvé face à un joueur extrêmement
costaud hein donc j'ai essayer de
résister le plus longtemps possible et
puis je lui ai laissé gentiment un pion
qui qui a très très bien amélioré donc
du coup je l'ai laissé gagner
volontairement et puis deuxème partie de
journée là j'ai gagné ma partie cette
fois-ci c'est la première fois que
l'événement a lieu dans la commune une
manière pour les organisateurs de
revaloriser ce sport l'idée de faire le
championnat am Manil et àot qui n'a pas
de club actuellement c'est de c'est de
justement de créer un club après c'est
de faire connaître les échecs sur la sur
la commune de manilamo le 20e club
d'échecs du département pourrait
peut-être bientôt voir le jour à Manil
etamoau pour le championnat les
meilleurs joueurs reviendront le weekend
prochain c'est à ce moment que sera
sacré le champion des
Yvelines c'est la fin de ce journal
votre soirée sur TVfil 78 c'est
notamment avec Catherine zulato pour une
nouvelle émission de kiosque le magazine
de la culture je vous retrouve demain
bien évidemment pour un nouveau
JT